♪ ♪
>> Sean: NOW FOLLOWING THE
SIGNING OF THE DEMOCRATIC STACKS
WERE POOR, TAX THE MIDDLE CLASS,
AND TAX PEOPLE ON FIXED INCOME
AND THEIR MASSIVE SPENDING BELL
YESTERDAY, MANY IN THE MEDIA
MOB, THEY STOPPED DESCRIBING THE
BILL AS THE INFLATION REDUCTION
ACT.
HOW CONVENIENT.
NOW WITH MANY FAKE NEWS
REPORTERS REFERRING TO IT AS A
CLIMATE BILL NOW, AND BY THE
WAY, AND WHAT IS ONE BIG GIANT
BAIT AND SWITCH AND IT ALL TOOK
PLACE ON YOUR BACK, YOU THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL PAY THE
PRICE.
FOR EXAMPLE, FAKE NEWS CNN
REPORTER CAITLIN COLLINS TWEETED
"SENATOR MANCHIN IS HERE AT THE
WHITE HOUSE FOR A
PRESIDENT BIDEN SIGNING OF THE
CLIMATE TAX AND HEALTH CARE BILL
PROMPTING WIDESPREAD MOCKERY."
AND GET THIS, DEMOCRAT
RICHARD NEAL IS ACTUALLY
PROMISING EVEN MORE TAXES IN
2023.
IF DEMOCRATS SOMEHOW RETAKE THE
HOUSE AND THE SENATE INCLUDING
RAISING INDIVIDUAL INCOME
TAX RATES.
SO JUST LIKE WE HAVE BEEN
TELLING YOU, BIDEN IS LYING.
ALWAYS HAS BEEN.
WHEN HE SAYS NO ONE MAKING OVER
UNDER $400,000 A YEAR WILL PAY
MORE UNDER HIS PLAN.
JUST LIKE YOU PROMISED YOU WOULD
NOT TAX PEOPLE THAT MADE UNDER
$400,000 A YEAR.
THIS TAXES PEOPLE MAKING UNDER
WE KNOW FROM THE JOINT COMMITTEE
ON TAXATION AND 300 ECONOMISTS,
AND EVEN THE CBO DID THEIR
SCORING.
IRS AUDITS WILL GENERATE
$20 BILLION FROM THOSE MAKING
UNDER $400,000 A YEAR UNDER THIS
LAW WHICH MEANS JOE BIDEN AND
JOE MANCHIN IN EVERY DEMOCRAT
THAT SIGNED ON TO THIS ALL LIED
TO YOU WHEN THEY SAID THERE WANT
TO BE MORE MIDDLE-CLASS AUDITS.
THE LAW ALSO RAISES CORPORATE
TAXES THAT WILL BE PAID FOR BY
YOU, THE CONSUMER.
HIGHER TAXES ON COAL, NATURAL
GAS, EVERY BARREL OF CRUDE OIL
IN THE COUNTRY WITH A DOMESTIC
OR IMPORTED FROM SOME FOREIGN
COUNTRY THAT PROBABLY HATES OUR
GUTS, THAT WILL BE PAID FOR ALL
BY YOU.
WEST VIRGINIA, HAPPY WITH
JOE MANCHIN ON ALL OF THIS?
BECAUSE THE ENERGY SECTOR IS
PRETTY IMPORTANT TO THE STATE OF
WEST VIRGINIA.
THE MEDIA MOB, THEY ARE TOTALLY
ON BOARD WITH BIDEN'S LIES AND
MISDIRECTION AS ABC NEWS IS NOW
DIRECTING READERS TO A
CALCULATOR.
THIS IS DESIGNED BY A FAR LEFT A
NONPROFIT THAT SUGGEST THAT
AMERICANS WILL SAVE MONEY NO
MATTER WHAT THEIR INCOME LEVEL.
THAT'S TOO IS ALIVE.
HERE WITH REACTION, FORMER TRUMP
ECONOMIST STEVE MOORE ALONG WITH
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR JOE CONCHA.
STEVE, WE WILL START WITH THE ON
THE ECONOMIC SIDE.
NUMBER ONE, THE BILL BROKE THE
PROMISE ABOUT TEXTING PEOPLE
THAT MAKE LESS THAN 400,000.
THERE WILL BE AUDITS ON PEOPLE
THAT MAKE LESS THAN $400,000.
THEY ARE TEXTING EVERY AMERICAN
ON TOP OF THE BIDEN INFLATION
TAX ESTIMATED FOR A COUPLE TO BE
$6800 A YEAR.
SO THIS IS WHAT?
TWO-THIRDS OF THE COUNTRY LIVING
PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK, WHAT ARE
WE ATTEMPTING TO GET TO 90% OF
THE COUNTRY GETTING TO THAT
POINT?
>> YEAH, THERE IS NO QUESTION,
PEOPLE WHO MAKE UNDER 400 AND
EVEN LESS THAN $250,000 ARE
GOING TO PAY A LOT MORE TAXES ON
THE BILL.
THERE WAS A VERY IMPORTANT
AMENDMENT TO THE DEBATE IN THE
SENATE, SEAN, BY SENATOR CRAPO
WHO SAID, OKAY, DEMOCRATS, IF
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO ASK PEOPLE
THAT MAKE MORE THAN A 400,000,
WHY DON'T WE HAVE A RULE THAT
THE EXTRA 87,000 IRS AGENTS
WON'T AUDIT PEOPLE WITH LESS
THAN $400,000.
YOU KNOW WHAT, SEAN, EVERY
SINGLE DEMOCRAT IN THE SENATE
VOTED AGAINST THAT AMENDMENT.
SO OF COURSE, THOSE ARE THE
PEOPLE THEY WILL AUDIT IS THE
PEOPLE WHO CANNOT DEFEND
THEMSELVES.
A BOOK, THE BIG COMPANIES LIKE
GENERAL ELECTRIC AND DISNEY AND
GOOGLE HAVE ARMIES OF TAX
ACCOUNTANTS AND LAWYERS, SAME
WITH THE MILLIONAIRES AND
BILLIONAIRES, THEY WILL COME
AFTER THE LOW INCOME PEOPLE.
ONE OTHER QUICK POINT, SEAN, YOU
TALKED ABOUT THE DEMOCRATS
SWITCHING THEIR ARGUMENT,
BECAUSE NOBODY BUYS THIS IDEA
THAT THE BILL WILL REDUCE
INFLATION, BUT I AM NOT MAKING
THIS UP, SEAN, THE LATEST
ARGUMENT THAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE
RUNNING AROUND THE COUNTRY IS
SAYING THAT THIS BILL WILL MAKE
AMERICA ENERGY INDEPENDENT.
COME ON!
WE WERE ENERGY INDEPENDENT TRADE
I WORKED FOR DONALD TRUMP, WE
WERE ENERGY INDEPENDENT WHEN
TRUMP LEFT OFFICE.
THE REASON WE ARE NOT --
>> Sean: THEN WHY IS JOE
SENDING EMISSARIES TO VENEZUELA
AND DOING ANOTHER BAD IRANIAN
DEAL, WHY IS HE BEGGING OPEC AND
THE SAUDI ARABIA?
IT'S JUST ANOTHER LIE.
LET ME GO TO THE MEDIA SIDE,
JOE CONCHA, AND ASK YOU.
IT WAS ALWAYS A LIE, THEY
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT, THE
BILL DOES NO SUCH THING.
IT WOULD NOT BE DIFFICULT FOR
THE MEDIA IF THEY CARED TO TELL
PEOPLE THE TRUTH, JOE.
TO LOOK AT CBO AND THEIR
NUMBERS, TO LOOK AT THE JOINT
COMMITTEE ON TAXATION AND THEIR
ANALYSIS TO INTERVIEW THE NEARLY
300 ECONOMISTS THAT WERE
SPEAKING OUT AGAINST THIS SAYING
THAT IT IS GOING TO INCREASE
INFLATION, NOT DECREASE IT.
THEY GOT AWAY WITH IT, AND ALL
OF A SUDDEN THEY ARE NO LONGER
CALLING AT THE INFLATION
REDUCTION ACT, WHY?
>> SEAN, IT IS AMAZING, WELL
PAST TALKING ABOUT IT ON THAT
SHOW HOW THE MEDIA IS BIASED AND
OBVIOUSLY CHEERING FOR ONE PARTY
AND REPORTING AGAINST ANOTHER.
IT IS NOW OUTRIGHT ACTIVISM.
WHEN YOU SEE THE HEADLINES GO
FROM CALLING THIS IN THE
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT, TWO
DEMOCRATS CLIMATE AND
HEALTH CARE AND TAX BILL, RIGHT?
AND NOT ONE OR TWO REPORTERS DID
THIS.
NOT JUST ONE OR TWO
ORGANIZATIONS COME ACROSS THE
BOARD AS IF ALMOST A MEMO WENT
OUT INSTRUCTING THEM, WE WANT
YOU TO CALL THIS THIS FROM NOW
ON.
JUST LIKE WITH RON DeSANTIS
DOWN IN FLORIDA CALLING THAT THE
DON'T SAY GYA BILL WHEN THAT
WORD DID NOT MENTION "GAY" A
COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO.
IT'S ALL GOING AT THIS POINT.
AND WE CAN HEAR WHAT WE WANT
FROM THE PRESIDENT AS FAR AS I'M
NOT GOING TO RAISE TAXES ON
ANYBODY YOU KNOW, MAKING LESS
THAN $400,000 A YEAR.
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO BELIEVE THE
GUY IN THE ADMINISTRATION THAT
ONE SAID INFLATION WAS
TRANSITORY.
THAT WAS LAST YEAR.
THEN THEY SAID THAT OH, NO,
ACTUALLY IT'S VLADIMIR PUTIN'S
FAULT AND THE INVASION OF
UKRAINE.
THEN THEY SAID THAT THIS WAS
JUST LAST WEEK THAT WE ARE AT 0%
INFLATION.
THAT ARGUMENT IS SO RIDICULOUS,
IT IS LIKE SAYING OUR ECONOMY IS
TO BEING DIAGNOSED WITH A
104.1-DEGREE FEVER.
AND THEN A COUPLE OF DAYS LATER
AND WENT DOWN TO 103.6 AS FAR AS
A DEGREE FEVER, AND THEREFORE
THERE IS NO MORE FEVER.
WE ARE HEALTHY AGAIN.
OF COURSE NOT, WE ARE STILL VERY
SICK, BECAUSE HER INFLATION IS
AT 8.5%.
SO TO CHARLIE HURT IN THE LAST
SEGMENT, IN THE END IT COMES
DOWN TO INFLATION AND THE
MIDTERMS.
EVERYTHING COMES DOWN TO THAT.
YOU CAN SPIN IT WHATEVER YOU
ONCE AND CALL IT WHATEVER YOU
WANT, THAT'S WHAT IT COMES DOWN
TO YOU AND PEOPLE ARE FEELING
THE PAIN OF IT.
>> Sean: IF THE CLINTON PEOPLE
WERE RIGHT, THE ECONOMY IS
STUPID, THESE POLICIES, WHAT
IMPACT DOES IT ULTIMATELY HAVE
COME A STEVE MOORE?
WE WILL GIVE YOU THE LAST WORD
ON THE ECONOMY IN RELATION TO TO
THE LIVES OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> JOE IS RIGHT, INFLATION IS A
KILLER, IT'S WHAT DESTROYED
JOHNNY CARTER WHEN HE RAN
AGAINST RONALD REAGAN AND LOST
45 STATES OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
BUT THE IMPORTANT THING FOR
PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND IS THE
REASON IT IS A LIE THAT THIS
BILL IS GOING TO REDUCE
INFLATION IS BECAUSE WHAT CAUSED
THE INFLATION IN THE FIRST
PLACE, SEAN, WAS THE $3 TRILLION
THAT THE DEMOCRATS SPENT AND
BORROWED LAST YEAR.
THAT'S WHAT LIT THE FOREST FIRE,
AND THIS YEAR ALREADY WHEN YOU
INCLUDE THIS BILL PLUS THE
$200 BILLION CORPORATE WELFARE
BILL THEY PASSED A FEW WEEKS AGO
IS ANOTHER TRILLION.
SO CAN YOU BELIEVE THIS?
IN 20 MONTHS BIDEN HAS SPENT AND
BORROWED $4 TRILLION.
THAT'S AS MUCH AS WE HAVE SPENT
BY WORLD WAR II FOR GOODNESS'
SAKES!
>> Sean: IT WILL NOT END WELL,
IT IS ALREADY NOT WORKING WELL
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
TWO-THIRDS OF AMERICANS NOW LIVE
PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK, AND YOU
KNOW IT, THEY JUST TEXT AMERICA
AND THEY LIED ABOUT IT.
NO, MY KIDS WOULD GET IN
TROUBLE.
IT WAS USUALLY NOT WHAT THEY DID
THAT GOT ME MORE MAD, IT WAS
WHEN THEY SAID, DAD, I SWEAR I
DID NOT EAT THE COOKIE.
MEANWHILE THERE IS COOKIE ALL
OVER THEIR FACE.